I feel like I put like a glue stick
under my arm or something and it just
stained my skin
the first time ever I'm bleaching my
armpits I was afraid that this might
burn but it doesn't burn at all ha ha ha
ha ha ha sensual oh yeah
no one I knew was excited that I was
doing this but I'm doing it anyway my
number one purpose is to make people
laugh I'm excited
if you had told 12 year old me that 23
year old me was gonna dye my armpit
hairs I'd be like wow I'm a mom of two
kids now so I really don't have time to
do grooming anymore and I'm really over
shaving knowing that I was going to dye
my armpit hair was a great excuse not to
shave and it let me just like let it
loose and free and it was really freeing
this could be the most extreme thing
I've done I think that those who matter
to me know already what I am about
and they won't judge me based upon a
decision that is on the surface when I
was 12 and it were my first tank top and
I had hairy armpits and people said oh
my god she has hairy armpits look at me
and I just look at her and it felt I
felt uncomfortable I just feel like it's
a personal choice and it's fine for
people to do things their way and I
think that women are starting to break
free and embrace their own standards of
beauty and not let them be defined by
other people Wow I see you I accept you
it's cool
here it is me
it looks like my armpits goblets period
looking like a skin disease at this
point but you know maybe if I showered a
couple times would wash off my skin and
stay on my hair I think I should have
chose a different color if I had grew up
my hair even longer
maybe when we've gotten some better
results I feel a little giddy about it
right now
I'm probably gonna snapchat my mom in
like five minutes and be like look what
I just did aren't you proud she'll be
like no look you surprise yourself when
you do something that makes you step out
of your comfort zone I think this would
be a good bonding experience for either
with my friends or me and my sister do
you love your body own it like do your
thing